consumer clip kommt noch mit jungs
komplett rein und jetzt gehen wir rein
und seen um ein kopf münchen meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einem video über meine vum tour in
minecraft ich habe mir gedacht das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen wenn ich einfach
so durch meine wohnung um laufe und euch
das ganze so zeige und da das gaming
kann alles und nicht die kultur für den
relaunch von meinem rennrad kanal
geplant hatte habe ich mir gedacht ich
zeig euch das jetzt erstmal minecraft
hier auf meinem computer gaming kanal
und zwar ist das hier mein zimmer so
sieht das aus ich wohne im park bin
penner und das ist mein kühlschrank und
hier packt immerhin hier scheiß mich
einfach so anders
nein natürlich nicht das hier ist meine
bude also die signifikante aus sondern
das ist jetzt geht auch um die jugend
uhr nicht um die haustür oder so vor
allem weil ich auch meinem haus wohne
luca ebenfalls wohne ich in hamburg wo
genau sage ich nicht und das sieht auch
nicht vor meiner tür so sandig außer mit
den bäumen und so aber es sieht von
innen schon mal finde ich wie ich bin
sehr nah ran gekommen meine wii wirklich
meine wohnung aussieht und jetzt sage
ich einfach nur mal vakuum djuric kommt
noch mit jungs komplett rein und jetzt
gehen wir hier rein und seen um einen
kopf so da sind wir jetzt hier drin ich
mache die tür hinter mir zu und zwar ist
das erst mal so hier kommt man halt so
an so einem fahrstuhl geht dann ihr so
raus macht die tür zu und dann sieht man
erst auf der linken seite hier ist und
so ein vorhang vor und da sind auch noch
mal so türen die türen sind direkt dran
also es ist natürlich immer noch
minecraft ich kann nicht alles perfekt
hier darstellen weil das halt immer noch
ein spiel
die türen sind eigentlich hier so direkt
davor also die tür direkt vor und hier
ist ein kleiner vorrat
das ist aber meistens wirklich immer
offen dass es nur zu gern mehrere gäste
kommen als wenn jetzt von mir
vorbeikommen brot ganz normale kumpels
von mir vorbeikommen abends irgendwie um
eine runde fifa zu zocken oder so ist
das natürlich immer offen
aber wenn irgendwie mal weit ich habe so
kommen dann aber plötzlich mache ich das
eigentlich mal zu und das ist einfach so
ein bisschen meine stau cover und zwar
habe ich hier verschiedene fächer wo ich
beispielsweise socken drin habe
unterhosen die stars blabla hier habe
ich beispielsweise ein paar sachen drin
weil sie nicht so sachen die ich einfach
nie brauchen wie beispielsweise
irgendwelche verträge die ich irgendwie
abgeschlossen habe irgendwie über
youtube oder in den studien vertrag oder
so oder
hier sind auch irgendwie solche sachen
drin wie beispielsweise sport sachen die
ich dann einfach die hand benutzt sind
und so ihr halt einfach so der ganzen
krims krams sie stehen so ein paar
bücher wie beispielsweise menke taylor
volkswirtschaftslehre so was in die
richtung dass für die uni brauche und
auch so ein paar sachen die ganz
interessante interessant sind zum
beispiel habe ich so ein paar jährchen
sohn fakten buch bekommen alles mögliche
also das war ganz cool eigentlich habe
ich da halt immer so drin stehen
hier sind dann so meine styles also da
habe ich jetzt bei rüstung stände
eingestellt eigentlich hinter so bügel
wo ich dann so ein paar sachen drüber
engenhart die hosen oder hemden oder
irgendwie so und ja das ist eigentlich
schon mal in meinen schrank der ist
jetzt nicht wichtig in minecraft ist ein
block 1 meter also das jetzt nicht vier
meter der ist eigentlich so eine type
oder zwei meter nur wenn ich das alles
so kleinen minecraft darsteller finde
ich das richtig drauf deswegen hab ich
das jetzt ein bisschen größer als
dargestellt
hier ist dann so eine palme die heißt
norbert den hab ich ja so genannten weil
max drache in galaxy s auch norbert ich
mir gedacht okay kommen also und norbert
es doch eigentlich gibt es oben hin
aber es gab nicht so eine hohe pflanze
und das einzige was gegeben hätte wäre
hohes gras und dass sie eigentlich
keiner aus deswegen einfach so dahin
gestellt
hier hängt mein mantel von brad ist die
marke glaube ich daten nicht viele
gefragt bei dem casting sport ihr bei
der you messe wie der heiße ist von der
marke bei rottweil hat den anderen hast
du die ak her
also wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr da mal
vorbeischauen dafür bekomme ich nicht
alle die jetzt wegen spot paceman er
will kommt dem mantel geschenk nein das
ist sehr schön
ich weiß noch damals ich habe damals in
videos immer irgendwelche von ihm
welchen marken erzielt und da gab es
nicht mal product placement alle dachten
youtube wirkt sich ähnlich entwickeln
und das keiner rum gemeckert und jetzt
auf einmal wenn man eine marke sagt
direct jeder hier bekommt dafür 10
millionen euro oder so aber naja
jedenfalls ihr müsst euch übrigens auch
vorstellen hier sind überall halt türen
also hier ist eigentlich eine türen und
hier ist mit werden das ist quasi mein
eingangsbereich mit fluor und da in
meinen klamotten hier ist so mal in
meinem wohnzimmer wo ich arbeite wo ich
chile wo ich schlafe und wo ich koche
und hier ist mein badezimmer also es
besteht quasi aus einem zimmer das
zimmer
dann hier flur und das badezimmer und
hier sind doch eigentlich mal so tun
aber diesen eigentlich immer offen weil
ich das finde wenn die türen zu sind
fühlt man sich eingeengt und somit zum
aufnehmen habe ich die türen hier immer
zu damit das nicht so ganz so viel halt
und ist ruckelt der zurückgedrückt
arbeit neue pcs da und ich bin der
dampfer produzieren das video müsste
wenn alles klappt am 25
da habe ich den neuen pc schon aber wenn
gerade in österreich aber das erste
video mit dem neuen pc wird dann am 29
jedenfalls ist das hier mein bart der
lichtschalter befindet sich hier da kann
er oft und nicht da oben an das hier
soll so eine art handtuchhalter sein
also hier ist ein handtuch
ich hab's vergessen hier muss eigentlich
auch noch seinen handtuchhalter hin aber
ich weiß nicht kann ich das rein
theoretisch kann ich da nicht so ein
haken dran anderer art perfekt also das
ist doch auch was ein handtuchhalter da
ist dann ist ein kleines handtuch halt
so wenn ich hier im badezimmer bin hier
ist eigentlich auch noch eine spüle und
so aber die hab ich jetzt nicht hin
gemacht sondern hier bitte könnte ich
aber auch mal eben man merkt schon
gefallen hier beim bauen immer noch ganz
viele andere sachen ein und zwar hier
ist um eine spüle darüber ist also das
wo ich mir hände wasche und so also
nicht die spiele wurde nicht was spiel
nicht die spiele in der ich meine
geschirrspüler sowie gucke ich morgens
meine unfassbar hässliche presse im
spiegel haben wie ich mir die zähne
putze alles mögliche gehe hier auf dem
pott setze ich stell mich da rein packe
erstmal schön eindrücke hier drauf ab
und dann bin ich da drin
hier ist meine dusche ist eigentlich ein
vorhang aber es gibt keine vorhänge in
minecraft die man so mit rechts abziehen
kann das war richtig cool und hier hänge
ich dann einfach mal mein handtuch
drüber wenn ich geduscht habe und das
eigentlich auch schon das badezimmer
hier die dusche komme ich nicht anders
darstellen weil sonst das wasser über
geflossen wäre
und jetzt halt noch ein kleiner teppich
vor der dusche sandoz vorleger und jetzt
ganz cool weil er es auf einer toilette
und der teppich sie mal richtig warm und
wenn man da so sitzt und das ein oder
andere gespräch ab dass eine lange
geschäft abwickelt dann hat man auf
jeden fall einfach mit pfizer im stall
jedenfalls kann man hier also
weitergehen jetzt halt auch eigentlich
eine tür aber die hab ich halt auch
immer offen und rein theoretisch wird
das dann quasi so aussehen so die tür
einfach offen aber ich habe es einfach
gar keine türen gemacht weil es gibt die
türen bei mir sind weiß und es gibt
keine richtige tür in minecraft wenn ich
mir hier bei redstone show wirklich weiß
ist außer dass es aber
blöde dicke eisentür übrigens müsst ihr
auch wissen dieser belag auf dem boden
das ist halt dieses polit polierter ein
ende seit ich habe laminat und das ist
so weiß greulich ist laminat und das ist
halt holz aber das einzige holz hier was
ein bisschen heller ist es das hier dass
sie da war viel zu gelblich aus also der
boden ist so weißlich er
und da gab es allerdings richtig ist
nicht dass ihr denkt ich wohne in einer
fabrik oder hast du unfalls ist hier
dann den lichtschalter kann ich einfach
das licht hier oben mit an machen die
andere lampe die ich habe es hier über
meinem bett die ist dann das ist so eine
stehlampe die kommt von hier eigentlich
so hoch mit seinem stil und dann geht
die da so ein bisschen über das heißt
die lampe ist eigentlich da wo der
schalter als es für die skw kaputt
gemacht habe aber das konnte schlecht
darstellen in minecraft weil es ist halt
ein bisschen schwer mich am anfang schon
gesagt und die kann ich einfach wenn ich
im bett liege hier draufdrücken tauss
machen das eigentlich ganz cool weil da
muss nicht mehr aufstehen je das licht
ausmachen und an mich hinlegen und dann
hoffe ich auf dem weg dahin war alles
dunkel ist meine ganze bude hier um
jedenfalls haben wahrscheinlich schon
viele auf instagram gesehen wenn nicht
instagram punkt com
schrägstrich laser luca alle fragen mich
himmel herrscht schrägstrich con crafter
ist ein fake oder bist du doch gar nicht
schrägstrich laser luca so heiß ich da
und ich kann mich irgendwie nicht mehr
umbenannt aber naja jedenfalls habe ich
da so eine paletten konnte ich auch
schlecht darstellen dies aber richtig
geil falls irgendwelche inspiration für
eine couch braucht guckt einfach mal
vorbei mit instagram profil bisschen
runter scrollen
die steht hier die habe ich dann so
etwas dunkel gräulichen teppich mit so
einem kleinen tischchen wo ich immer so
sachen drauf wie mein portemonnaie meine
uhr schlüssel und so weiter hier vorne
ist dann meine küche und zwar sind hier
oben so sachen wie töpfe drin stehen
hier ist mein vorratsschrank mehr oder
weniger also da steht so was drin wie
wartet dass es eigentlich doppelt breit
leider steht so was drin wie kellogg's
oder nudeln oder
die so was in die richtung töpfl obst so
was in die richtung
hier befindet sich mein backofen da ist
eine dunstabzugshaube
hier sind meine mülleimer drin und hier
ist warte was wir da noch mal drin ich
glaube ich meine da drin sind teller und
so was in die richtung oder dass es da
oben und die töpfe sind hier keine
ahnung ja jedenfalls ist jeder an seinen
tisch de kann man so hochklappen und
runterklappen der ist relativ mobil also
damit erhält so eine wand melanie weg da
kann man sich dran stellen und irgendwie
morgens frühstücken und so da hab ich
dann meistens auf den laptop stehen und
informiere mich da noch über sachen wenn
ich in der uni muss oder so oder ich
habe hier so einen kleinen stuhl der ist
eigentlich auch schon auch so ein ding
hier darauf aus sein
also das ist doch ein stuhl jemand mit
einem hebel so hoch fahren kann sondern
drehstuhl jetzt ganz coolen kann man
sich dann auch so überziehen wenn man
mal hier was essen will oder einen
kumpel mit am pc sitzen möchte oder so
ja das ist quasi dann die küche hier ist
ein getrenntes abteil also das ist somit
zu verschiedenen fächern so vier mal
vier fächer ich konnte allerdings und 3
x 3 darstellen da ich hier sonst nicht
nur ins bett gekonnt hätte sie stehen
auch sachen drin die bücher da steht
auch drin meine sonnenbrillen dasteht
sonntag eine pflänzchen drin ein paar
handtücher mein genie wo man alle
anderen alben von disclosure und so ein
hinstelle bild steht da drin ein ordner
dastehen als andere sachen einfach drin
und das trend quasi ein bisschen mein
schlafzimmer von meinem wohnzimmer und
dem ganzen anderen schädlichen hier
hinter befindet sich mein bett ich hab
sonne die ist nicht so krass großen
punkte sondern geht so liniert
eigentlich wieso hellblau-weiß lich
meine bettdecke und hier ist dann halt
mein kopfkissen was auch so in dem in
der farbe ist dass es von ikea der
bettbezug und hier ist dann quasi mein
schreibtisch möchte also dran sitzen mit
lippen mit mitteln wie so lag somit dem
stuhl im stuhl sich daran hallo hallo
minecraft wieso lag so jedenfalls steht
hier drauf dann mein drucker das ist ein
bisschen erhöht die position für den
drucker und telefon als mögliche die das
bisschen runter und dann ist hier mein
vater das könnte ich ja sogar rein
theoretisch ihr merkt schon während des
videos fallen mir viel coolere sachen
wieder so sieht das ganze nämlich in
etwa aus hier drauf steht dann quasi
mein drucker dann geht das bisschen
runter dann steht hier mein einer hier
steht ein zweiter bildschirm und hier
ist halt steht halten man kann halt in
minecraft auf einen block nicht mehr
eine sache stellt das wissen jetzt auch
noch meine tastatur eine maus mine
complex von nicole also mischpult hier
ist meine schreibtischlampe mit der ich
mich hier beleuchtet also die kann ich
auch so runterklappen dann bin ich von
einer seite hier nicht mehr beleuchtet
sieht sogar ein ganz cooler jedenfalls
steht die da und ich nutze meinen
zweiten bildschirm das ist so nah 27
zoll bildschirm und man ist halt auch 27
zoll den nutze ich der hat zwei hdmi
ports und die nutze ich für die eine
seite von imac kann einfach sei nokia
die einzelnen ich habe mein weg und
andere seite hdmi 2 für ps4 dann wenn
mit zocken wollen wir das ding auch ein
dings hatten lautsprecher und wenn ihr
euch fragt worüber ich fernsehen gucke
ich kann auch ganz einfach einen tick
reinstecken und dann gucke ich darüber
fernsehen dass es eigentlich auch ganz
gut weil ich hab keinen bock mehr noch
einen bildschirm im zimmer zu stellen
damit viel zu voll und fiel zurück mäßig
also wenn ihr euch fragt was im
bildschirm oder so der steht eine
beschreibung das eine viel geld link zu
amazon und da könnt ihr dann schauen da
steht dann blau und block und der ist
eigentlich cool also muss ich wirklich
sagen sonst der kostet halt auf
dementsprechend aber ich finde ich cool
immer alles super geile tonqualität
reicht für alles aus also bin ich sehr
zufrieden mit uns eine sehr coole marke
finde ich was zumindest
monitore ange besser als samsung also
meiner meinung nach jedenfalls war es
das eigentlich schon da oben ist meine
lampe hier ist noch kein gemälde das
wäre dann ja quasi hier übrigens meine
paletten wenn jetzt seht schaut mal die
stehen da gerade hoch kann hier solche
paletten sind das darin immer schaut und
zwar stehen die hochkant weil ich da ein
bisschen aufräumen war bislang saugen
putz weil ich jetzt auch schon drei
monate hier wohnen da muss man lange
beim bauern machen und das gemälde soll
halt eigentlich dann ihr mann hierhin
kommen und zwar sollen da ganz ganz
viele instagram bilder von anderen
youtuber die ich cool finden wenn welche
in amerika bahn und da irgendwie was
fotografiert haben oder so oder wenn
welche in kanada unter wasser sind oder
so und da für fische fotografiert haben
es gibt halt viele coole fotos ruhig
sagt das möchte ich nicht noch mal
machen im leben wenn ich zeit habe und
so das möchte dann hierhin hängen dass
wir dann so eine riesige wand findet ihr
demnächst richtig viele fotos außer ich
werde bald nach köln ziehen eventuell
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher weil da
ist halt einfach ich bin ich kann auch
von der uni hin das ist alles normal
also das kann ich das gleiche studieren
da sind viele leute die schon kenne es
ist für mich für youtube sinnvoller und
so weiter und so fort
jedenfalls ist das auf jeden fall schon
mal meinen ruhm tue ich glaube ich habe
nichts vergessen also in diesen dingen
habe ich auch schon gesagt was da drin
ist eigentlich und sonst hier unten
steht auch noch ein mülleimer darunter
bei conti hat auch nicht unterstellen
einfach so wo man so papier
müll rein steckt und was alles und das
war meine hut achso übrigens wenn ich
aus dem fenster schaue jetzt hängt sie
wieder an zu ruckeln wenn ich aus dem
fenster schaue ich wohne in relativ
oberen stockwerk und da kann ich halt
runter gucken auf der straße und da das
coole ist da sind halt bäume vor und das
gute ist ein großteil der bäume vor sind
die nehmen so viel lärm einfach weg also
es ist wirklich so wenn er die
straßenbahn her fährt oder in bus oder
sondern wird schon mal laut allerdings
leicht hat diese bäume vorhaben ist das
richtig cool und auch wenn irgendwie
wenn's regnet oder irgendwie so dann
hört das echt ganz schön an und ich bin
quasi nicht an direkt über der straße
wenn ihr versteht was ich meine
unterzieht auch einfach schön aus muss
ich sagen hier ist das jetzt natürlich
provisorisch mit dem baum da unten aber
naja ich würde auf jeden fall sagen
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich selber eine bewertung freunde
zwar eine menge arbeit das ganze
aufzubauen
also es sieht nicht nach viel arbeit aus
aber man muss eine menge nachdenken wie
man sowas passend bauen passenden
starten sonst würde ich sagen sehen uns
in einem
video wieder und zwar morgen bei den
sechs wenn alles passt und klappt mit
dem hochladen und dann bis später